around one in every 100 people on the
planet is now a refugee the number of
people forced to flee their homes is the
highest ever recorded in many European
countries right-wing parties have
recently risen to prominence on an
anti-immigration platform and America
once a year in refugee resettlement has
more than halved the amount it receives
under President Trump keep these
foreigners from entering our country in
the first place
the second half of the 20th century was
defined by bringing down Wars and the
danger is that the first half of the
21st century is defined by the building
of Wars David Miliband is a former
British Foreign Secretary and head of a
global humanitarian charity he is also
the son of refugees who fled the Nazis
and came to Britain the refugee crisis
matters to me because my dad came here
as a refugee in 1940 my mum came here as
a 12 year old girl and I know that if
the UK had not admitted them as refugees
in the 1940s then I wouldn't be here
today
currently there are 65 million people
who have been forced to flee their homes
and over 20 million their countries
solving the refugee crisis is as much
about our values and what the West
stands for as it is for the future lives
of the refugees on the receiving end
here are mr. Miliband's ideas for
tackling the global refugee crisis
refugees are displaced for a long time
so they need the chance to work to give
them dignity to allow them to contribute
to the local economy in society
refugee status is supposed to be
temporary yet around half of the world's
refugees are displaced for more than 10
years during this time the majority
don't have the right to work but one
country has taken pioneering steps to
integrate refugees Uganda has made a
decision that it will allow refugees to
work in Kampala the capital all but a
tiny number of refugees were off
humanitarian assistance completely
because they were supporting themselves
through work this example deserves
praise and my raishin from the whole of
the international community education is
a lifeline not a luxury and half of all
the world's refugees are kids 3.5
million child refugees don't go to
school this is bad for them and it's bad
for their country of origin if and when
they return home most of the world's
refugees are hosted by poor and
middle-income countries
[Music]
the top-ten refugee hosting countries
account for only two-and-a-half percent
of global income I think it's very
important that the responsibility of
Western countries is about aid to
support those countries that are hosting
refugees although some Western countries
have taken in large numbers of refugees
few refugees receive long-term
resettlement packages of the 22.5
million who have fled their countries
less than 1% have been resettled in the
West very few refugees make it to the
richer parts of the world fundamentally
because those countries are closing the
doors permit
traditionally the US has taken about
90,000 refugees a year a president Trump
promised 45,000 in fact he's on track to
deliver only 21,000 refugee resettlement
places the number of refugees resettled
elsewhere in the rich world is small I
[Music]
want people to believe that the refugee
crisis is manageable not insoluble
because the policy solutions are there
this is a global crisis not just a
Middle Eastern crisis and it needs a
genuinely global solution
you
you